hi I'm Evan Carmichael your friend and
all things entrepreneurship and today
mention the question from one of my
youtube viewers Joseph who wrote in to
say by the way which mobile phone do you
use and why so this is my phone I use a
Samsung Note 2 and I was coming from the
ipad and the ipad obviously a much
bigger you know tablet and i wanted
something with a phone and I couldn't
imagine having the ipad up against my
ear talking to somebody I saw a guy at a
bookstore have this little hand strap
that he put on his iPad and he was
talking to somebody just looked at maybe
a little bit too ridiculous for me so I
wanted something that was still big
enough of a screen but could also be a
phone so that's the main reason why I
picked this one I love using it because
it incorporates all of my files from my
desktop and from my laptop so all the
services that I try to use on my phone I
make sure that can get the files
available anywhere so I have my email in
here obviously I have my Dropbox files
on here i have my evernote files on here
and if i make an update here on my phone
I'd automatically goes to my computer
now a lot of the phones have the same
apps and same functionality but I like
basically the size of this and the speed
of it to be able to you know take around
with me and it still fits in my pocket I
use it in my videos so it's easy to kind
of scroll through when see who's left me
a comment and I will pull it up and say
you know Joseph asked me a question and
i'll use it in my meetings as well if I
don't my laptop with me or I'm not in
front of my desktop I'll just pull up
Evernote and I find the screen is big
enough to be able to make comments and I
can still kind of read it and then it
automatically syncs again with my
desktop and my laptops and my notes are
all in one place if I need it so that's
a quick tutorial I guess I'm the phone
that i use and why thank you for the
question if you guys like this video
please give it a thumbs up below makes
me to do more and if you have a question
about this video or comment I love to
hear we have to think in the comment box
below thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you